[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
ya conmigo en el estudio nuevamente el
luis méndez zúrich y louis vamos a
hablar de eeuu heleno europea que se
reunieron ayer en bruselas para analizar
y avanzar que va a ser el bloque de los
27 en su disminución de la dependencia
por el gas ruso o louis así es por ello
establecieron un acuerdo donde la unión
americana se comprometió con los países
que integran la unión europea para
garantizar su
exportación de gas a ese continente por
lo pronto el acuerdo contempla el envío
de unos 15.000 millones de metros
cúbicos de gas licuados adicionales al
año pero el objetivo a largo plazo es
garantizar al menos hasta 2030 el envío
de unos 50 mil millones de metros
cúbicos de gas al año pero escuchemos
qué fue lo que dijo el presidente
estadounidense sobre ello
señora presidenta lo sé eliminar el
gasto ruso tendrá costo para europa pero
no sólo es lo correcto desde un punto de
vista moral sino que nos pondrá en una
posición más sólida
zigic su link para ello eeuu se ampara
en que luego de convertirse en el
principal productor de petróleo del
mundo para enviar a hacerlo también en
con el gas de acuerdo con datos de
eurostat la unión europea importó en el
año 2019 el 41.1 por ciento de su gas
procedente de rusia luego está noruega
con poco más del 16 por ciento así otras
naciones de acuerdo con el medio español
el mundo estos primeros 15 mil millones
de metros cúbicos responden a una parte
de los contratos para adquirir casas
ruso que ya están firmados pero este
acuerdo ya empieza a generar reacciones
y muchas de ellas en contra así
respondió el diputado manu pineda quien
calificó la iniciativa como un gran
negocio para eeuu y agrega que serán las
familias trabajadoras europeas las que
pagarán caro en su efecto apagarán la
calefacción pero porque se refiere al
precio lo primero que debemos decir es
que este gas llegará a territorio
europeo a través de embarcaciones es muy
distinto al gas que actualmente llega de
rusia y que lo hace a través de tuberías
el envío por barco aumente en un 40% el
precio del gas por ejemplo un artículo
del diario eleconomista de españa' del
24 de febrero señala que en ese país
pagaron previo a la invasión rusa un
promedio de 53,8 euros por
megavatio/hora por el gas estadounidense
en contra de los 38 como 42 del gas
procedente de rusia y el banco central
de rusia a luisa reaccionó las
afirmaciones del primer ministro del
reino unido sobre un posible intercambio
color y es que la máxima autoridad
británica señaló que rusia podía estar
utilizando el oro para evadir las
sanciones impuestas ante ellos el banco
central ruso indicó que todo su oro está
en el país y de acuerdo con la agencia
de noticias rusa interfax adicionalmente
refiere
hay manera de evitar las sanciones
impuestas en dólares y euros por otro
lado el medio señala que el ministro de
finanzas ruso anton siluanov señaló que
las sanciones privaron a rusia de
300.000 millones de dólares de sus
reservas y un día crucial para la
economía argentina a louis y es que hoy
está previsto que el fondo monetario
internacional discuta y apruebe o no el
acuerdo establecido con la nación
sudamericana para el pago de la deuda
que ronda los 45 mil millones de dólares
el directorio espera durante la reunión
de este viernes aprobar el acuerdo que
en argentina ya tiene el visto bueno del
congreso con ello podría emitir un
primer desembolso por 9 mil 800 millones
de dólares que servirá para abonar los
vencimientos al corto plazo y además
robusta hacer las reservas del banco
central argentino indicadores bis por
supuesto que toda esta atención en
ucrania y rusia además de la volatilidad
de los precios del barril de petróleo
provocaron cierres en mixtos en los
principales mercados de asia asimismo en
europa también en
registrado leves ganancias a lo largo de
la presente jornada para finalizar que
nos trae como cifra el día y tiene que
ver también con este conflicto y la
posible contracción de un 15 por ciento
para este año en la economía rusa de
acuerdo con los datos del instituto
financiero internacional todo ello por
la crisis que se está viviendo a partir
de la invasión de ucrania louis gracias
por toda la información de economía
feliz fin de semana nos vemos la semana
que viene con más pasamos ahora a hablar
de cultura